This is a site we have built with grids
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now.
I copy the grids URL from the site
and paste it here.
Hitting okay,
I am then asked to confirm the messenger
signature request or the message
signature request.
I hit okay
and you'll see I am now logged in.
Almost instantaneously, I am logged in
to the secure client portal and
dashboard.
No password, no credential transmitted.
Now I'm going to show you a transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the grids URL. I paste it
into the grids URL box and I now get a
transaction signature request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay.
That's already done.